laurent baffie était allé voir les gens
dans la rue pour leur parler de
françoise hardy et l'astrologie est
prête à tout à fait une chanson
mouchoirs je serre les dents voilà
laurent baffie
bonjour est ce que vous aimez françoise
hardy sur le plateau de double jeu âgé
1,4 à cette émission
quoi qu'il en soit et sur le plateau
elle ne chante plus ah oui c'est dommage
parce que j'aimais bien ces champs sont
censés consacrer exclusivement
l'astrologie est ce que vous voulez
savoir je salue des plus rien parce que
son grand frère celle arrêtée donc la
série d'exemples petit haut risque pour
demain oui j'ose hardy a fait ses
preuves l'astrologie elle dit pas de
métro pour demain raison bien
spécifiques
elle voit une catastrophe pour vous si
vous prenez le métro de moscou un
accident c'est à guy badie du tout
scorpion ascendant scorpion comme alain
delon mais dit elle tiens je ne savais
pas ok oui allez vous dit que la
conjoncture est très noir pour demain
les problèmes de dos madame pardon
renvoyé d'une minerve conseil demain
d'aller voir votre toubib qui arrivait
une erreur de diagnostic qui pourrait
entraîner des séquelles graves pour
demain un bon elle m'a dit qu'en ce
moment vous avez le mercure dans
l'uranus et c'est chaud pour vous en ce
moment là aussi en amour yann laphin
comme le calme plat ouais bien sûr mais
personne n'est absolument pas même le
confirme c'est pas demain que j'avais
trouvé la femme de votre vie
elle vous dit que n'êtes pas à l'abri
des fautes de goûts rock et madame et me
demande si vous vous habillez parfois
sous l'emprise de la drogue
non pas du tout elle me dit que c'est un
sacré blaireau bon vous devez être 1 1
c'est vrai qu'on est un sacré que tard
également
ah bon vous aimait beaucoup les femmes
bah oui pourquoi pas je n'ai pas
toujours d'une honnêteté exemplaire avec
elle ah bon vous avez des aventures en
ce moment me rendre auprès spécialement
spécialement elle comprend vous pouvez
pas parler elle veut elle me dit vous
dire que
ça va aller en s'arrangeant pour ce que
vous savez y'a bon vous êtes des petits
poèmes de parfois deux
dejean et des petits problèmes
gastriques pas du tout pour fouler un
peu du du boulot moi je sais pas je vois
pas des docteurs depuis 30 ans évitez le
karaté la moto à la moto oui éviter la
photo dit c'est ouais ouais ouais ça
passe ou le deltaplane
vous ne pouvez régler je peux passer de
130 l'horoscope de par des passants pays
est valable c'est françoise hardy commun
pour corte sont payés alors ils me
l'avaient pas demandée excusez moi vous
permettez à bien vous permet tout
non merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu